[Music]
all right let's move on now jennifer
aniston has written a lot of zeros to
help victims of the recent hurricanes
she just donated 1 million dollars split
between the American Red Cross and the
Ricky Martin Foundation which of course
is for his native Puerto Rico meanwhile
Jennifer Lopez and Alex Rodriguez have
joined forces to aid those in need as
well we talked about that and why they
are just so good together when they sat
down for the very first time as a couple
it's gotta feels so good
how how people just love you too as a
couple it's incredible to see the
reaction out there and how much people
are kind of like you know into this I
think we're very alike in many ways and
I think that's what makes it work and I
think that's what people respond
we're like except I can't say an
undeniable chemistry that has now
evolved into the ultimate modern family
collaboration Marc was like I'm gonna do
a concert down here and I want you to be
a part of it
the couple has joined forces with
Jennifer's ex-husband Marc Anthony for
Saturday's celebrity-packed
disaster-relief benefit one voice somos
live I called every performer myself it
was a lot of fun to call you know Gwen
Stefani or Demi Lovato or Leonardo or
any of these people Ellen DeGeneres and
go hey my full-time job is now Puerto
Rico and can you help me out and they I
can't even get the sentence out and
they're like yes what do you need I've
actually seen her nervous and stressed
and superwoman never gets stressed what
is it look like what does it look like
we're doing
it looks like Danis sleeping anyway baby
baby oh I can't sleep I want it to be
right I know how much the people in
Puerto Rico need it like I know
firsthand how much they need it and so I
want I want it to be good
you
[Music]